as I just mentioned the national weather
service has extended that heat warning
once again so we send it over to Nate to
find out if it's ever going to cool down
well eventually originally when the
excessive heat warning was first issued
it was going to expire tonight well
yesterday it was extended until tomorrow
now it's been extended until to make
that Thursday night so here we have a
great view a couple of clouds here and
there but man we are already way warmer
than we were at this time 24 hours ago
up to 105 degrees at noon no wind to
speak of humidity is way down the dew
point is definitely now this five
degrees warmer than we were 24 hours ago
so the excessive heat warning will
expire tomorrow night for Northwest
Arizona but for most of southern Nevada
much of Southern California now going to
run until eight on Thursday night that
is the first of our weather headlines
hope you enjoy the lower humidity while
it lasts because coming up in the eight
day forecast Heather the monsoon watch
comes back